from kim's maryland moment to blake
lively's red carpet transformation we
have got the met gala's most gilded
style stars welcome to entertainment
tonight let's bring in our golden girl
rachel smith in madame tussauds new york
in times square ah rachel have you
recovered yet look kev to be honest no i
have not neither have my feet my dogs
are still barking but enough about me
let's start with the king and queen or
shall i say the mets mom and dad blake
lively and ryan reynolds
honey you nailed the assignment tonight
co-chairs blake and ryan brought the
drama a team ended the oversized bow on
blake's copper versace gown which when
released turned the dress green and not
to how the statue of liberty also
changed from copper to green in color
way to go blake i looked at new york
city architecture for this event this is
detailing from the empire state building
some of the draping from the statue of
liberty
did you saw your hesitance look at him
he's a smitten k he just turned his head
speaking of statues that's rihanna
shutting down the met in marvel the
singer who's due any day now skipped
this year's gala but was honored inside
with her very own artwork
the style icon usually closes down the
carpet but this year kim kardashian pete
davidson making their debut on the met
gala red carpet how are you feeling in
this special dress tonight kim
this is marilyn monroe's dress
it's 60 years old and she wore this when
she's saying happy birthday to president
john f kennedy in 1962
i tried it on it didn't fit me and so i
looked at them and i said give me like
three weeks and i had to lose 16 pounds
kim told vogue she wore a sauna suit
twice a day and cut out sugar and carbs
later back at her hotel kim was ready
for mini donuts and pizza i'm so excited
you're gonna let me jackie oh tonight
mama chris kept the kennedy vibe going
wearing this yellow oscar de la renta
gown similar to one first lady jackie
kennedy wore to a state dinner what do
you think of mr pete dave i think he's
great you look handsome you look hot
thank you she didn't let me wear my
propeller hat but it's fine
and just minutes before hitting the red
carpet chris kim chloe and kylie learned
an la jury had sided with them and blac
chyna would not be awarded any damages
in her defamation case against them i'm
just glad it's over
well the party was just starting for
these ladies going solo
[Music]
i got married so i just felt like it was
appropriate that i come to the ball and
celebrate that
gwen stefani's neon two-piece was a nod
de vera wang who also made her wedding
gown she was without blake while katy
perry sans orlando squeezed into an
oscar de la renta corset don't ask me
how i'm gonna go to the restroom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
also solo and stunning haley bieber
nearly eight weeks after being
hospitalized and sjp giving us sex and
the city vibes her usual met gala dates
andy cohen stayed home with new daughter
lucy tell our friend andy
congratulations on little loose
i know you missed your plus one
[Music]
gigi and bella arrived 22 minutes apart
gigi's burgundy puffer code gave us
cardi b met gala 2019 vibes and speaking
of call me buddy buddy thank you who's
sitting at your table i've heard
i've heard cardi b
which would be fun gigi and donatella
all
one name wonders right there
wow so good ladies
cardi clearly understood the gilded
fashion assignment just eight months
after baby
no lipo surgery can bring this body that
my son gave me
mama quick changed and let loose at her
own after party
yadda yadda
okay it's the bag
we rolled deep in the mosquito party bus
oh everybody was partying up top you
don't have to get at the bottom where
the air conditioning was
both magnets stallion and lizzo were two
of the mets biggest fangirls lizzo
showing off her flute skills
is this your airport outfit for tomorrow
you pulled that last year
shawn mendes was a meme worthy disney
prince and made sure to arrive before
his ex and urita camila cabello who went
from this to this two men helped with
her train as she nailed this all right
look let me see those nails right
they were like you want to do interviews
i was like yes i got an album out
emilia get that promo
it is the match so you know what can i
say and can we talk about this jared
leto doppelganger that's actually
influencer frederick robertson who had
stars inside and even the new york times
doing a double take the real jared he
was stuck in the house of gucci totally
twinning with its creative director
alessandra michelle
meanwhile plenty of couples were having
the ultimate date night
jody you've got the ultimate hype man
today
joshua jackson made sure his gorgeous
wife jody turner smith's gilded gucci
train was picture perfect for their met
gala debut all right
joe jonas and wife tuffy turner were
also couples goals
the duo showed off their growing baby
number two under sophie's study louis
vuitton like kim their after party was a
pizza shop which was a big couple's
theme tonight it will be pizza
and cheesecake gabrielle union and
dwyane wade earned it his
behind-the-scenes secret was mountain
climbers and abs
the former miami heat star delivered a
sizzling shirtless moment my wife told
me to leave my shirt in the car well
you gotta do what you said the best
[Music]
are you getting this entire magnificence
alicia keys and hubby swiss beats were
in an empire state of mind
alicia's ralph lauren train featured the
city's skyline while swizz wore a new
york city varsity jacket we're both from
new york and ralph lauren is also from
new york new york city forever
we got the night off from the babies so
we're uh we're gonna pull out all the
stuff with one-year-old daughter lila at
home henry golding and wife live low
lived it up
newlyweds brooklyn beckham and nicola
peltz made their red carpet debut as
husband and wife so did james mcavoy who
secretly married his very private love
lisa liberati she's very
adverse to the limelight so the fact
that you got her to come here i'm like
wow you're good magic powers nice to
meet you i'm lisa
and it was a couple's debut for casey
musgraves and boyfriend cole schaefer as
well as kaia gerber and new man austin
butler james gordon gave a big ol thumbs
up with wife julia carey after
announcing his late night departure
after next season you had a very big
week how are you feeling
[Music]